este martes se cumplen siete meses del
inicio de la cuarentena en argentina
para intentar contener el avance de la
pandemia 19 el lunes se conoció que el
país había superado el millón de casos
de esta enfermedad convirtiéndose en uno
de los países con más casos en el mundo
además el número de muertes alcanzó los
26 mil 716 esto significa que en
argentina a pesar de la implementación
de esa cuarentena temprana y tan
extendida la enfermedad sigue avanzando
de hecho una suerte de migración primero
estuvo más concentrado aquí en la ciudad
de buenos aires y el área metropolitana
de buenos aires en los alrededores de la
ciudad y luego fue migrando al resto del
vasto territorio argentino hacia las
provincias del interior donde hoy se ha
hecho más fuerte algunos señalan algunos
especialistas que la posibilidad de que
los contagios se hayan sostenido tanto
en el país puede tener que ver con que
no se implemente un programa lo
suficientemente fuerte de testeo y
rastreo de posibles contagios y por eso
creen que es ahí hacia donde debe
con el país y el gobierno un gobierno
que defiende su accionar e insiste en
que si no hubiera implementado esa
temprana cuarentena la situación hoy
estaría mucho peor porque no se podrían
haber preparado los sistemas de salud
del país